on this week's show how to persuade your
partner to invest in property in the
news property bosses are raging against
the rent cap plan for London raging I
love it and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
hi I'm Sally I'm Alistair Cunningham and
welcome to this week's show he's gonna
be a good show it is but you know
something like super exciting
you know raging about it I know gone
what do you do last week oh yeah why are
you asking me this is normally the other
way around back to last week I was in
Miami I know you won't
that's why I'd come back with a bit of a
suntan and blonder hair than usual The
Sun has dyed it blonde yeah it was it
nice was it warm and it was a very warm
how did you get five degrees
oh this is yet an expensive week didn't
you I did have an expensive way I heard
yeah and I thought I saw yeah so few
quid I spent a few quid on a bit of her
some shoes didn't yeah that was some
although were worried well actually may
I tell us what happened what happened
well we went to Gucci yeah and he bought
two pairs of shoes and then we got to
the attorneys are I'm McCord amis you
thought I was a lot of well but you can
spare me the money over mate he's like
yeah yeah well and then he didn't so I
just messaged his wife
thank you transfer me over over 1100
pounds please well nobody is like hey
why does transfer 1100 over to you boy
it won't want there are a nice extra
quid I've got yeah per pair what else
did you spend some money on when you're
out there
well I just I wouldn't spend that much
money on pair of shoes no personally
okay but whether I spent money on but if
you invest money I mean you're invested
man I'm invested money in training yeah
I know you did an education she would
tell her lessons just how much that was
necessary we told everyone from the
crash course I didn't Samuel says how
much you spent mm - no two hundred
thousand pounds yeah yeah a lot so guys
that's worth it
just so you know when we promote from
stage and when we promote our father
education as a company we are actively
investing in our own education I'll get
a return I invest it I invest in
education to get returned and you do
everything by overtone and investment of
course I can't wait for it because I'm
gonna I want some of it as well yeah I'm
going out to Miami next month to do the
same course for a staff quite a bit of
it for our staff to be investing in our
staff as well absolutely
always invest and always investing in
education you can't you can't get enough
know any good so yeah a good wait really
hot I got sunburned hmm on the first day
I'll give you a picnic if you want to
put it on now so everyone can see
did um have much time for sort of them
so I just chilling out or were you're
constantly event I had a day at a day
either side how how it's called but we
actually worked did you what was Miami
likely and as a watchman I've never been
to Miami water so every not it's it's
beautiful
it's really hot like I said was 35
degrees very humid yeah the cost of
living is very expensive out there
it surprised me how expensive because I
thought America was cheaper than
didn't make the certain parts of America
like nine dollars for a coke there's a
well what line of court name doors are
cheap that's not bad is it
oh you mean a can of coke calico oh it
was like you know a gin and tonic about
$16 mmm
virgin time maybe if you got a manly
drink I went out for an out for a steak
right and you know you know when they
they bring you there bring you like
these steak and then normally you've got
other things on the side of the plate of
it yeah
so they brought out just a stage to
sneak rightly and I was $70 for this
stake right and I was like I was waiting
I was sitting there waiting for the I
thought they were gonna bring because it
was a few of us we just all had a stake
yeah and I was expecting them to bring
out the veg and stuff and putting them
into the table and after about five
minutes
I just thought they're not they
literally have just ordered a yes seven
eight dollars stay yeah you have to
order all the side set right over there
didn't you like if you order like a
stick it just comes taken and you have
to order side of fries okay see here
it's like you would restate it just
comes with stuff doesn't it just says
steak on the menu but water literally
just this very best steak I've ever had
to be fair yeah it was it was did you
hire a car and stuff was get on a bus
really hot really nice beautiful
beautiful out there loved it was great a
lot you know a lot of good people at the
events and everything he was great yeah
a little sit-down mentoring with their
grant Caudill I did that was a good
video wasn't that it was and you there's
good on YouTube
no I was really surprised yeah but
that's good though it's really good it
was obviously we've got him no mentoring
our mentoring us for our period of time
so it's cooked yeah he's great great guy
great guy right awesome so this week how
to persuade your partner to invest in
property one of the common problems that
people that they'll come to us and I'll
say hey I really want to I really on
bias property everyone this but my wife
is not supportive of majors or husband
or husband we're saying that because
we've got wives yeah or husbands in York
I don't know but I've got a wife so
we're say that's asked where we're
coming from isn't it so yeah right if I
I'm not trying to be sexist here if I
keep referring to wife and just coming
from there on that that makes sense
disclaimer at the bottom disclose I am
NOT sexist yeah no it's just it's my
wife yes I get that I get that and to be
fair when I first started my wife's very
supportive of me now it probably when I
first started investing in property you
know before it was tried and Ted but you
know when we were new to it because
Samuel had just started and was due
who's doing well and I'd have been about
nine we'd never very much money is about
19 at the time
and my wife was very much like no it's
risky don't mean to do it so I can kind
of relate to that I've become and
probably see a lot is people's partners
one person's like yeah this is crazy I'm
going to do it yeah another person's
like you are bloody not that's calming I
see all time and it's not just with this
it's with everything I think if you're
with our a partner that's not like that
it's the opposite to you although it's
good that's good in many aspects
sometimes it's not when it comes to
growing a business or grew in our like a
venture you're doing first thing first
thing I would say as well is it's not
just buying in property a lot of
partners a couples don't see eye to eye
on finances in general yeah absolutely
maybe it comes from the different
backgrounds that if you've got one if
you've got one person from like a a
business type environment and business a
family background and you one person
from not then there's a bit of clash and
but spend save spend a saver yeah she
was spending us over I'm a bit both
because I'll spend on the right things I
don't waste money
I'm not a squander la squats quandra and
I don't waste money on on rubbish um
like I'll spend a lot of money on
something that's good because I see the
value in it but I say okay fine right a
prime example yeah go on on his example
ok Hoover's ok prime example is it yeah
absolutely right if you've got carpets
ok you want one probably the best Hoover
you can get ok
so I've had this before where we went
out and we bought our Hoover broke and
we went out and we bought just our cheap
old I don't know just to get it quickly
because all they had in stock we bought
like a 70 pound Hoover and it was it was
dogs it was complete rubbish it saw as
well as finally Oh bleep it it was
complete rubbish 70 apparent to me that
70 pound wasted I would rather spend
seven hundred pound and get the best
Hoover out there because to me I've
wasted 70 pounds on a Hoover it doesn't
work doesn't do its job but again I
would rather spend seven hundred and get
the thing that does the job and does it
better
well so what would you have right now we
have a GTECH do you take care of I'm
never very good better than Dyson it's
better in bison because it's more solid
it's rigid
Dyson's have become a bit plasticky in a
bit flimsy the quality of Dyson's gone
down you've heard it here first
I've got a Henry Amy's good why do you
think every cleaning company in the
country use Henry's but I went actually
I say hammer not in a 125 pound us when
they're looking that much no they're not
really good and the good
you got hit II know you've got Henry
Henry
it's the Henry brand but it's not Henry
okay I've got James James James is the
yellow one you know why because Annan
wanted whoever that was a lightweight
and James like a Henry best much lighter
why are we talking about who was do you
know the guy who like a couple of weeks
ago we had the guy talk more not about
talking about teeth we're gonna get this
guy back on my tongue
movers goddamnit this property but who I
mean but who was that that's value for
money so your wife you're paying for the
pretty seats like 100 quid some oil and
also why would you spend one to seven
hundred quid on Hoover if there was an
example it was I wouldn't spend civil in
front and Hoover but it was an example I
don't care how much it is as long as it
does the job and it works so how much
your Hoover I think was like two hundred
nine quid okay but to me spending 70
quid on something it doesn't work as a
waste of money it's complete waste of
money but the problem is if you've got a
saver on a spender in a relationship
you've got one person who's always
trying to skimp and save money you've
got other personable that will spend
money on the right valuable stuff so
that can cause an issue when it comes to
investing in property and things that
are yeah because obviously if you've got
one person it's like no no we have to
save save save save save all our money
like and save all my and they'd like to
see a bat ah I'm about a balance of
money building in the bank then you're
all a person like well that money's not
actually doing anything in the bank
let's invest and some that may make more
money there's going to be a clash yeah
so what are the steps that we can take
the steps that we can take to advise
people that if they walk if they're
doing property in the trying to get into
it and they've got a partner perhaps
it's not really sort of fully behind
them what can they do to try and win the
move on I don't like what was there's
two ways you could kind of go for it
yeah alright so the what
one way would be to work out budget so
so go okay what things important to you
where things are wanting to make ya more
budget for because to be fair your if
you're the one that's wanting to invest
you're probably not in letting them by
their you'll probably try and stop them
buying their designer clothes yeah you
trying to restrict them or whatever you
know they may see your investment as a
restriction mile follow the restriction
on their ability to spend the money on
yeah yes it's like so work out like I
well what we'll do we'll save 10 percent
of our money to invest in property and
I'll give you ten percent of your money
to blow on football tickets I was about
this you can pick this creamer off no
but yeah do you know I was just gonna
say this comes back to the money jars
yeah which obviously simply teach you
the crash yeah so yeah we talk a lot
about this at the if getting down to the
crash course and you'll learn a lot
about this but that's what one one way
you can do you can budget the other way
is you need to be able to you know this
is where I always talk about selling
right selling you're always selling yes
selling is key to every whether you're
in business whether you're the cleaner
whether you're whatever it is that you
do you need to be able to sell and this
is an example of that example your job
now is to think about how you how you
can sell to them that they need to
invest in property and you need to you
need to win them over that that is what
you need them to do haha the crash
course just gone right I at the end of
the day when I look who just come off
stage right at the very very end and I
had a lot of people come up to want to
pick me and there was a husband and the
wife come up and she come up to me fast
she gave me a massive hug and she said
thanks very much nothing and she said I
really want to thank you because you've
changed my whole mind about things and
she told me the story of how her husband
dragged Torah they are her husband
literally dragged her they out she
didn't wanna comment she only came
because he was going and she had no
intentions of getting involved in
anything it flipped she was no like
super pumped about property and he was a
bit more he was getting a bit more
he was still see he still what to do he
was just decide he was just to say yes
now she's like gone up above him she's
like no we're doing this we're doing
this were joined the Academy were doing
this and wasn't he interesting way of
doing is to get the first step could be
to bring him along to math crash course
for example because then but was she
because someone message me on when it
was the same person what was her name I
don't remember her name unfortunately
but do you know a good thing to do it
and also is to try out your a role play
it all be the let's pretend we were a
couple okay okay
I'm man shotgun man okay suppose civil
marriages is in though yes I'm the giver
it's you have to go there yet right so
you have to go it's a really
relationship yep and you want to invest
in property and I don't you guys what
you guys wrong with me over I just got a
weird image of made no right car we
don't I never like I found the woman
fine
right so what was the question
sweetheart alright I think that this
property game is risky and to be honest
I don't I don't I don't want to do it
I'm I don't it's a waste of our money
I'll just I don't want to blow our
savings on a headache my mind just
didn't okay well look I understand why
you're saying that
okay but why don't we do it properly and
then just do it one step at a time and
just see if we can make it work for us
but I'm just not interested I'm just I
don't but why are you not interested
what what horror stories have you heard
has made you not interested in I kind of
her i watch this program on homes into
the hammer yeah and they've got experts
there helping them and they bought this
property and they thought was something
over valium it didn't they lost their
money they went bankrupt and now they're
living on the streets in a cardboard box
okay darling did you ever consider you
know have to call me darling okay
did you ever consider not right now not
when you're trying to force me to buy a
property anyway did you ever consider
that the BBC will only show worst-case
scenarios now so they are not going to
show you the success stories because it
doesn't say how it does that
so when they when they when their patron
Iseman so when they're airing when
they're looking for people to go on
these shores they're not gonna advertise
hey you are successful property landlord
that's got lots and lots of houses that
are all working perfectly because that's
boring they want the scum of the air
that are not paying their rent and
leaving the properties and trashed
conditions so that's that's that that's
that that's one scenario on homes under
the hammer for instance and they're not
going to pick the cases that always are
successful because that's just boring so
I would say like we've worked hard for
our money we've worked hard to save up
we're not willing to squander it we're
not just gonna Billy nilly willy nilly
waste it let's do it properly let's get
out of there get the right advice and
just take one step at a time and we'll
do lots of viewings and then we'll just
take one set but then we're and will
only invest when we've done all of our
research and we're comfortable with the
investment and the risk for convinced
yeah
no no well I'm gonna do it anyway so if
you don't like that no long time ago I
think I think I probably in all honesty
I can't really answer this question
probably because I've always had support
to support
I've always been supported and so I've
never but I do sympathise with people
that don't have supportive partners but
you know when I used to work for snap-on
tools well hey we would be sailing stuff
to mechanics and that and that they
couldn't buy anything well getting
permission for the matter from their
wife so the partners like they did one
buyer like a set of screwdrivers was
like sixty quid and they'd have to ring
their wife and get permission and I
might meet when you ring her ask her for
your dignity back she's got it in her
handbag they said come on man do you
really need to bring your wife and ask
her for permission for everything did
you say that I didn't see that I can't
see what I would see on your did you did
you like insult them at what I did yeah
really
we were friends like we're not friends
but we dealt with on a regular basis I
said come on man
when you ring or ask her for your own
manhood back because draw the IRA dirty
if I was a virus if I was in a situation
where that they were there I think I
would talk some about what they what
they wanted so I think I think I'd say
to my this let's say you're the other
person doesn't like it yeah you're the
other partner okay right hey I went on
this brilliant property investors crash
course and I really think that we need
to start investing in property I'm sure
you do
why sure I do know cuz you always do
this if it's not this it's something
else okay
well I'm getting the feeling that you're
not overly positive about it no I I just
I think you've been you've been told
it's easy and you think it's easy but
it's not actually easy okay okay maybe
you're right maybe or maybe it's not but
listen I tell you what obviously we're
both in a job at the moment Yeah right
and my goal would be for us to be come
together to come financially free okay
do not mean well but finally free yeah
I've heard that saying ended around
YouTube if you haven't just watched last
week's podcast you'll know that what it
means but okay and what I was thinking
is I want to work out what our plans are
for the future okay so at the moment
we're both looking at jobs working
really hard
I almost spend more time with you and I
want to travel the world so let's write
down let's write down what we would do
if we were financially free okay okay
okay
how cool would that be how much do we
need to make this happen okay brilliant
so this this would be a goal yeah the
question is now we want we want to
achieve this how are we gonna actually
how are we gonna how we're gonna do this
I'm I'm thinking that property is an
option possibly and there's this event
on called the property investors crash
course yeah and I wondered if if you
wanted to come with me have a look we'll
check it out see what we think we don't
have to invest but we'll just give us a
flavor of what's possible is worth doing
what you reckon want to come oh you're
making it sound very appealing yeah why
not all right awesome let's go along and
let's and then let's see what we think
yeah that's a good way to do it it's a
very good way to do it because yeah I
think you need to keep your partners and
your partner involved as well and what
you're doing and whatever you're doing
but yeah I think it's a really good way
to do it cool I'm just talking my head
but I was mean we've had people we've
had people join join our Academy they've
never told the partner of the
I'm not going to see who it is but we've
got one particular guy who's never told
this part and Hurley is on he's on the
Academy I don't like I don't like that
either cuz I like to be transparent I to
be honest my relationship like now I
would just do it and I'll just I'll by
the way the pants on
I wouldn't ask permission no and but it
depends on your relationship and and it
also depends I see I make a lot of money
so if you can afford it I feel like I'm
I can do that if I was putting ah life
savings into it it's a very very
different situation
so like when when I was first when I
because obviously I've been with Anna
now since I was 14 and even back then we
used to like a paper round together and
we used to save the money up together
yeah but she got left some money from
her grandpa grams of MAG rama which she
put she put into into our joint pot okay
there's no way other than I spent that
money no no money we've saved together
so yeah it does it does it does depend
on what I don't think just because
you're in a relationship where I do you
should be able just to go and spend it
on what you want no I think I think this
all comes down to communication with
your partner I don't try and do anything
behind behind her back or behind his
back just literally I think communicate
tell me what you want to do and then you
ultimately I don't know any relationship
but they don't have a similar endgame do
what do they want they all want the same
thing don't they they all want to become
financially secure mmm I don't know
anyone it doesn't want completely secure
do you know exactly everybody wants
become financially secure so all you got
to do is try and work out an old method
of getting there yeah and you've got
trying to it in a way without upsetting
your partner and without risking your
partner and your relationship yeah and
just sit down and communicate work it
out and make decisions be very
interesting to see what you guys think
and get some feedback from you just as
our disclaimer we do not offer marriage
advice as you could probably tell it son
seek professional help but in terms of
persuading them to invest in property I
think I think you want to go I think you
want to look for what they want yeah and
and then and then just align it
yes let's aim anything in sales you find
out what they want in there and you
align it and the truth is like you say
everyone wants to financially secure
Yokoso your joy if you believe in
property and you believe that's the way
forward
look don't be like I want to do this
it's way yeah we won't do this one thing
I would just end on right is most
partners are not or not they're not
restricting and holding you back because
they just like that that do not have a
fear it's done out of fear because they
think you're going to lose money or
you're going to lose something or waste
or whatever so it comes contracts
communication education and just having
a clear goal plan end gaming and goal to
what you want and but it it's done out
of it it's probably done out of a
protection sort of thing that they want
to protect what they've got because they
don't maybe understand what you want to
achieve so that comes back to
communication but I mean like I think
most partners are pretty supportive of
if you do something new like I don't
know what for me lot I'll go back and
I'll but I am for this book I want you
to read it you'll read it yeah you know
I mean you want something a volume we do
that to me you always bought something
miss you know I've just read this book
we don't and you send me on yeah I've
got look about ten books have got
together I learn something new I want to
share it 100 tenex and the grant cardone
one last question how long it took me to
read I read I listened to that whole
book seven and a half hour book or
listen to it in one day yeah yeah yeah
that's cool if you've got yeah that's
good I mean I was flying back from
America in fairness yeah yes good use of
time though most people don't do that on
a plane but now and they watch movies
and sleep yeah good footage to remove oh
yeah it's move on it's now time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week property bosses
rage against Sadiq Khan's London rent
cup so mayor Sadiq Khan on Friday called
for rent controls to be imposed on
London landlords in order to protect
tenants
okay what's he proposing but his plans
triggered fury from property bosses who
fury fury what did you say it was
thought it's a fury and rage rage it was
like very very em descriptive wasn't it
yeah the industry got to be shocked to
con calling on the government for extra
powers to cat rents in London the
demands came in a serious proposals
including ending no-fault evictions he
said it's it's high time for the private
renting inland and to be transformed can
also flow to temporary exceptions from
rent controls to build floated temporary
exemptions from rent controls for bill
to rent homes and tax incentives to
encourage investment so when they say a
rental cap if he if he if you said what
it is he hasn't he hasn't said what it
is but he's just talking about putting
in a rent a rental cap in place does he
mean like a percentage or a like a
percentage of the property's worth or
does it mean like are the odds a month's
big on imagining he's a monthly figure
so the article doesn't say meaning they
could see they just see that like the
rain caps 10,000 pound a month that's
not gonna fake much as it because
there'll be a small percentage of
properties above that and there'll be a
lot people not that many as a percentage
come on dude
we've been looking I know you don't know
how much it is to rent like a house in
looking very nice house and somewhere
like Chelsea get is know or somewhere
like where was I was like in he become
stirred yes seven seventy thousand plan
a month no more 180 what a month yeah
hundred eighty thousand per month yeah
away were you man
dude I'll show you right now 180 grand a
month to rent huh I went on till I was
almost looking places to rent and I just
put I didn't put a half price I'll just
sort search from highest I thought when
it wants to be nice and then you know
I've changed my mind
once an uppity off the floor
yeah hojun I ran them up oh well that's
that's crazy
how much does a house worth millions and
millions of millions I imagine yeah but
if it's if you get underneath run a
month and rent a lot good investment
into maybe not not about passive income
yeah okay that's fine but I mean I've
been looking a law and like if you ain't
getting much in London for lesson two of
fifteen sixteen hundred quid on you for
a nice Hampstead within a mile I'm so
being annoying let's go back hold on I
wanted to rental don't I well I can tell
you something Jeanette grand I've done
it okay one hundred eight hundred net
you around and Wow so that's like a lot
of my name is quite a few for that price
as a percentage I needed an even okay
okay that guy had a good the crash
course yeah you know you might have
noticed this podcast lessness an estate
especially does it on stage when he
walks on stage he can't help himself he
just goes he tries to say okay but he
can't say okay so he goes okay didn't
every time every time really every time
well I obviously do because house like
you were really good apart from when you
first went on you bet okay and as I was
telling him this he got given this mug
yes I was just telling him about how he
always says okay he opened it picture of
him on the other side and it was on one
side on the other side it said okay it
does
Oh HHH HHH KY okay yeah it's interesting
because I've never met that guy before
so he's obviously picked up in it yeah
but there's a couple of them
Charlotte off the Academy she she always
sort of there takes the takes of dual
coding before it's a joke out yeah well
I was going to say take to make you
happy
it takes mickey out of me for it which
is funny but to see the hearings they're
trying not to sweat to slow his brain
Steve yeah it's I loved it money he's
gonna say about living the the balls in
the banking if I'm not gonna say ball so
leave your man eternity yeah
it's sort of a joke out of me anyway
okay so it was just interesting that
he's never met me and he's obviously
he's probably got it from the the
podcast and if you see me on stage mind
you he gave me a mug as well picture of
me I want something worse I said pull
his shoes up your socks up pull your
shoes there blue socks up and I'm now
got it forever
you know for the next week's episode
we'll have them to have you at your car
I've got it yes yeah we'll bring them in
and we'll show you on next week's
episode
I bet we forget and we will forget
there's no way there is no way I will
think my podcast mug I just was just not
considering we don't even plan the
podcast what we actually talking about
before we waffled on about okay do what
the news I mean capital rent rent is try
find out no it's not that ballin
interesting really is it it doesn't say
in the article but it just says that
they're at they're annoyed I imagine
it's probably a percentage yeah that's
what that was it that was it so as of
the whole of London the properties are
above 10 20 grand probably not the right
morals for saying it's a small percent
the the vast majority are under ten
thousand pound a month like the the
largest percentage at all so I'm
wondering if it's a percentage cap
increase so they can only increase it by
a percentage every probably a couple of
years away well but do you know what you
can't do nothing about it it's wrong
though I know it's wrong but because
it's always half what the government do
but do you know what if you say what
it's wrong because we're gonna do about
it sure I say you should be able to rent
a half whatever you want of course you
should but we live in a country that has
laws so yeah a sucker up except there or
lead the country but most of those are
correct like I'm not saying that you
should be able to go around and murder
people you know that's a correct law I'm
happy with that
that's good yeah but I'm not saying to
be able to go around stealing from
people correct laws I get that I get
that but in the Bible it doesn't say
thou shalt not increase that rent do not
mean maybe maybe in Leviticus somewhere
sorts and run themselves I don't think
it does I'm pretty sure it doesn't right
I've just done it okay right so anyway
okay all right um does it matter
well we can't change it
we can protest against okay you pull it
yeah you protest I'm not gonna protest
and piss and moan on a podcast exactly
as it was the point we can either focus
on the the the rubbish job that the
government do or we can just walk around
it what is successful people do do they
focus on the negative bill [ __ ] and the
negative news that comes out onto the
just you know walk while find a way to
get round up let's just find a way to
get round it gets his car impounded yeah
so all you people going protests have
fun yeah go protests have fun on behalf
of us when you're doing that telling the
property message podcast Senya
yeah yeah when you're doing that we're
going to be like having fun that day
somewhere else doing something
interesting like filming another like
film in another podcast or you know just
enjoying some time but if you want to
employ a stand strong then get crushing
Samsung parties all right it's now time
for this okay so it's time for your
questions now if you want to ask us a
question the best way to do it is to
jump obviously that's comment on YouTube
yeah obviously it's cool or jump on the
Facebook group of property investors
with Samuel Leeds we'll do a Facebook
live in there before before we film and
then we find the questions so we've got
a few coming up or from Facebook so the
first one here we go I'm gonna ask this
from Joshua Naismith right it's nice
with a Scottish surname maybe I don't
know there's of a Scottish footballer
called nice move I was just in know
Scotland had a football team
not a very good one anyway
what happens if you have a lease option
agreement set up with someone and they
pass away what happens if the owner of
the property also decides to sell at any
time would that be a case for a lawsuit
just got a lease option agree with a set
up and our lawyer said they technically
they can technically sell the property
regardless the contract may be not
legally but apparently have the power to
do so is this true okay
okay so why are you
firstly what whose support he was a
solicitor be handy to know that this guy
cons I know they can't I and secondly
you need have you used the proper lease
option solicitor I've used a normal
property solicitor there's a big
difference because when you do this list
the the lease option contracts you have
three parts of it one of them is power
of attorney so if they pass away you've
got power of attorney over the state and
you have a control and a property I
think it's an Rx one I can't remember
the exact title of it if you use the
right ventricle they can't say I'm sure
it's an RX 1 which means nothing can
happen to that property without your
permission because you have control of
it which means therefore it has to go to
court before you before they can they
can sell it they can finance against it
but if you've used the proper lease
options list oh they should be advising
you correctly so I'm not going to give
legal advice if your solicitor they has
told you that they can say like I would
check I would find the better selecting
the corners it sounds to me like you've
just used a randoms listen so it doesn't
know what they're doing
I would be speaking to one of the proper
lease option solicitors are out there
and we are we're out the DfE the
offending Stravaganza minute just
downstairs all the delegates are having
lunch with our solicitor that does this
so if you ever come along to one of
these events and yeah you'll get to me
him yeah cool all right next your a yeah
go on fire this is from Emma Yeomans mr
yeoman hey Emma
how do you handle full portfolio sales
from start to finish anything we need to
be aware of outside the usual property
sale process benefits and pitfalls
please well I've done one portfolio CO
and it was there was nothing wrong with
it it just went through normally as our
normal portfolio so each property always
has to be surveyed so you treat each
property individually but
you do as a whole a whole portfolio
still so the guy that was buying it was
using a portfolio mortgage and it was
just thought it's just a longer process
so I pitfalls I don't know really no
different to any just treat them as a as
a normal porches but em I give Mexico
you've got his number and he can advise
you a little bit better because he was
handling that sale for me so he meant
building if there's any anything he come
up against for instance and a member you
are officer on the mentor and so you can
you can't do that
cool awesome Martin Evans what are the
most effective sourcing strategies of a
budget of five would appear and month
how would you split this up when you say
sourcing so he's looking to source for
himself
I believe he's sourcing to pass on and
he's got five hundred pound a month to
spend on expenses probably I don't know
and well if you've got I don't know I
mean just go out there and start looking
petrol hotels petrol hotels I don't
quite understand the question submit but
what are the most effective sources
strategies the first most effective
sources strategies are just a find
entity home for sale at Booker let's
find an area yeah choose a strategy yeah
and then going for you a crapload of
houses in that area to maximize a five
hundred pound a month if that's what
your budget is for costs hotels and
stuff I would just focus on one area and
I would I would not I will not go into a
day of viewings and this I've got at
least ten viewings booked so the last
thing what I do is be driving back and
forth to areas or tend to look at one
property because it would likely be
cancelled and then it's true and that's
so true so book ten at least ten because
I guarantee you probably two or three of
them will be cancelled one one of them
the tenant won't let you in and the
other one the agent will probably show
apart so you may look at five if you
pick ten I don't know some are Ricky
Cole do you always offer bills include
in our HMO and if so what's the best way
to calculate costs and regulate it so
you're not open to misuse thanks
difference generally HMO includes all
bills yes and the I my experience tells
me that costs are approximately 40% of
the rental income approximation obvious
it depends on where you cross over but
what about just course on bills like a
so the cost overall are roughly forty
percent the cost of the bills and
depends on how many bedrooms but you can
get a good idea can't you off like
energy websites and stuff like that so
I'll just gonna say money supermarket
for your gas and energy bulb called at
UK for your gas and energy things like
you can bud you can em guess to me your
water usage by other properties in the
area just by going on to these sites and
broadband you can work out quite easily
council tax and go in the web the
council tax website and i'll tell you
the exact council tax bandung for that
property and just things like gas and
electric i would be using a smart meter
and a home hub type thing what they
called do you know that nick hive hives
pipes that's it may as a pension scheme
in it know they have a nest you can get
a nest thing that you it's called a nest
stake hive it's just so slightly cheaper
version I've got one in one of my houses
and it means you can control it control
the temperature from like so you can
have it sort set the last thing you want
is one of these all through temperature
controls where you can flick it the
constant because one of my HMOs that
you've got in the middle of summer
they've got the constant they've got the
water on Constance was constant and hot
all day and they've got the heating on
constantly but all the windows open so
you wanna be able to monitor that I am
quickly well got formal yes I throw gone
coin so early jandreau Castro okay I
think that's right if it's not apologies
Alexandra
we've deal sourcing what contracts do
you need to have in place a
nondisclosure agreement terms and
conditions source and contract and a
basic business contract there you go
speak to a good solicitor they would
roll them up for you Samiha Sam okay
there's got three questions okay and
then we're done yeah why the mall just
takes her along or Charlotte for a
different broker ask you ask you broke
up why did I take so long yeah
sometimes I've lost at houses because of
how long the mortgages have taken I'll
tell you why it is is because there's
too many people involved and you've got
to wait for this person to do this and
then this person can't do that because
they're walking on the next case and
then by 10 this person does that this
person's on lunch and then this person
do yeah Google broker just get a good
broker how long does it take on average
from offering
to get in the keys three months is the
HMO market oversaturated and is that the
reason behind article four no it's not
over saturated it's over saturated with
crap HMOs hang on that's so true
and it's only oversaturated in some area
and it is the reason for as before
because the council's trying to stop
areas becoming hate me yeah like what's
happening in Liverpool you've got
streets that are just hit Jamal's so
just we all say this to all of our
students and all of our people that come
through our training if you don't do HMO
just do high-end don't mess around being
a dodgy landlord be a good landlord
high-end good conditioning good
furniture good carpets good decoration
and you'll have no problem rental now as
long as you've done your due diligence
beforehand it's in a decent area and
you've done your dd-don't just take on
any old property because it's a cheap
HMO because the reason it's not let rent
now is probably because it's a dump
and that's it July d-day I don't know
how to answer that but I like due
diligence deed the I like DD a yeah like
I just got it and that is the perfect
way to end the show we will see you next
week 7 p.m. don't forget to subscribe
and every Saturday at 7 p.m. see there
take care guys see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]